hi guys today i'm here with ricky dillon
hey guys what's up I'm here with race
Ricky has just released his first EP so
basically you're considered a musical
genius right now
and the Grammys are coming up so I
thought this is a perfect time to talk
with someone who knows music better than
I do
I thought that we would do some
predictions okay go through some of the
categories and give our opinions on who
he thinks gonna win okay record of the
year the nominees are Iggy Azalea fancy
Sia's chandelier Sam Smith stay with me
Taylor Swift shake it off Meghan Trainor
all about that face my flavor his fans
affect everyone
oh yes Oh Academy I'm gonna go with Sam
Smith I was going to it I think they're
all great songs but I think the best
like overall with everything yeah the
best overall with everything that's a
music term I praise yah my backup choice
to see yeah I think she's great
I'll see you so Amin never shows her
face and they write what she writes and
everything and then she's got Maddie
from Dance Moms
in all her music videos and a memory and
I watched elastic heart and reacted to
that and that was an emotional I do
think it's gonna be the year of Sam
Smith I agree
makes me really excited to watch the
Grammys because I feel like we're gonna
get a lot of sad Taylor Swift face gifs
album of the year morning face my back
didn't know that is in the Mickey on say
Beyonce I didn't know that her album
what called Beyonce
no I didn't buy it get out X by Ed
Sheeran in the lonely hour Sam Smith
girl Pharrell Williams album of the year
okay ready one two three
Beyonce yeah where were you okay fun
story that's what Jack and Angela if you
know them we're visiting my house okay
and we went out frozen yogurt like 10
o'clock p.m. and we pulled up and Andrew
Andrew is the biggest I've ever met in
life you start screaming in my car any
it's like it's out the other element out
[Music]
but really that's a very special
experience first song of the year all
about the bass chandelier shake it off
stay with me take me to church one two
three shake it off I think shake it off
gonna go I know I really hope she hadn't
believed that I really liked that song
you two have a goal each song still my
favorite thing in association with
chandelier is Mary Hart recreating the
chandelier music video live at one of
our shows
[Applause]
[Music]
that dance is great but it's kind of
creepy she's like best new artist Iggy
Azalea best deal brandy Klark don't know
hands I am I am and choice of I'm a true
Irish and Sam Smith one two three
Sam said to me it's a toss-up between
Iggy Azalea
they both like blew up this year I think
bass feels great but I feel like they
won't like what they see um that song I
love that's hot wait we do one more
that's really exciting
Best Pop solo performance all of me last
one John Legend chandelier SIA stay with
me Sam Smith shaking off Taylor's with
happy Pharrell I witness one of these so
I'm gonna go with that because I was
there for a person so okay one two three
stay with me bye get out half of it it's
great I was at the VMAs and I saw so
okay well now we get to watch the
Grammys and see if any of our
predictions are correct yeah and do we
win anything for it
no not really we got a couple of big
tweets probably Ricky thank you for
being here thanks for having me make
sure you go over to Ricky's channel you
shot a video together that'll be up
there some point this month
just keep refresh as you look and go
check out you have two songs out now a
muse two music videos out right yes and
just EP is on my tunes and make sure you
check that as well thank you you're
welcome Grammy people for this free
promo yeah I don't know excuse me you're
excused thank you
I guess be watching the Grammys no do I
have to watch the Grammys now that we
made I feel like you have to because of
this yeah they're sorry